community that I acknowledge is you know
has been rocked by uh by me uh making
this Choice serving as a priest in the
way that I was was to was to say that
what I had felt and known and understood
was a lie and I could not do it my life
experience is a
Christian including struggling with
Christianity you know for years I've had
a Quran on my
bookshelf barely touched it I you know
commenced um theological studies and
that really made me drill down on the
Bible and on church history that uh that
was a you know a major motive in me
saying I need to take Shahara now
because you know no one
knows alhamdulillah brothers and sisters
we've acquired the future Dean Center
property and we want to get the mhid
open first it's all coming along we're
installing the doors we can make woo
we've installed the carpets we have many
details to finish up but it's coming
along alhamdulillah we need a new roof
we need new windows and we need a minbar
that's right we need a minbar for the
Masid now if all of you want to be a
part of history and help build a house
of worship build a Masjid for the sake
of Allah so Allah the Creator can build
for you a house in Jenna click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of
you alayum greetings of peace my next
guest he became an Orthodox Christian in
1978 and was ordained as a subdeacon in
1994 a deacon in
2017 and priest in
2020 being made Parish Priests of
exultation of the Holy Cross church now
he's planning to do umra for Ramadan
this year with the hopes to serve God
Almighty Allah the Creator in the dean
in Islam in the daah let's bring out
abdurahman the servant of the most
merciful David gud I'm very excited for
this
[Music]
[Applause]
interview and his final Messengers
muhamad peace be upon him this is our
religion Islam Islam this is the de show
I love you work that you're doing when I
was ready to talk about it I would only
talk to I was explaining how much
respect I have for the
fa
the
theam alaykum alayum Salam greetings and
peace how are you how are you I'm good
good thank you I'm good thank you Eddie
I just heard the amazing news a few days
back and uh we reported on it and we got
in touch and uh we're and alhamdulillah
you're on the program now amazing it is
amazing it is amazing uh Al truly works
in in amazing ways um let me start 45
years let me start by correcting though
45 years Orthodox not 45 years a priest
uh uh the internet being what it is is
would make me a lot older than I
am let's correct that so give us the
proper it's 45 years so I became
Orthodox in 1978 I was only a priest for
the last uh two years and a bit before I
um resigned to uh to become a
Muslim um so you know my life was spent
uh you know largely around from the age
of 16 at
um uh you know connected with Holy Cross
um I uh you know a community that I uh
have great affection and love for uh you
know a community that I acknowledge is
you know has been rocked by uh by me uh
making this
Choice um but it was a choice that you
know that I felt utterly Guided by uh
Allah to make um and that is you know I
I felt that
um uh my life experience as a Christian
including struggling with Christianity
um uh with with aspects of it um you
know it was a reflection of my search
for God and my search for God wasn't
really complete in
Orthodoxy um you know while I was
Orthodox through those years uh it's not
that I didn't uh you know look elsewhere
saying you know is this right
uh you know I became Orthodox in a in a
church that uh the the parish priesthood
died in
1973 I I became Orthodox in 1978 and we
had no resident priest from 1973 to 1994
we only had priests flying in every six
seven weeks from the mainland of
Australia so it was a kind of you know a
community without leadership and um and
so that that help shaped my my religious
life I guess
um it was a community that I loved and
which is why um when uh when I spoke
with my Bishop about you know send us a
priest he said well why don't you become
a
priest so you know in in in as part of
that requirement I you know commenced um
theological studies and that really made
me drill down on the
Bible and on church history uh and the
fact that so much uh that is in the
Bible in you know which as we know has
been shaped by by theologians and the
fathers of the church uh after many
years uh and and indeed centuries after
Christ was uh on this
Earth um that there was you know a mass
of accretions doctrinal you know
additions which got reflected in the uh
Constantinople and Creed and then the
subsequent Creeds uh you know
this uh as a spouse through the councils
of the church so I I I came to kind of
the conclusion that there was challenge
in the doctrine of the Trinity which was
not referenced in the way the church
teaches it in the way most Christians
Catholics Protestants Orthodox conceive
of the Trinity
and uh that was you know
problematic but
uh it was not you know an intellectual
um uh conviction that brought me to uh
to
Islam uh so I'll recount you know what
happened um I had to uh go to Perth to
my uh brother-in-law's funeral to
support my sister perth's on the other
side of the country you know 5our flight
away and when I went there I I I booked
a hotel and I I I noticed when I booked
it that it was you know only 100 100 150
yards from the Perth uh main Masjid
which was actually built uh at the turn
of last turn of the 19th and 20th
Century uh I I think substantially by
Afghan uh immigrants who who were
brought over in the days before rail to
bring uh camels because they were like
you know the long they were the
equivalent of trains of their
day uh and while there were earlier uh
mards set up in Western Australia and in
other places this one was you know a
substantial one built and anyway I was
staying very close to it uh and every
day I you know I walked around it past
it and and I felt this you know call to
go and visit it but I was nervous you
know I was an orthodox
priest um and uh nonetheless I chose to
go in and I went and sat in this lovely
Courtyard Garden nobody around just sat
and thought you know about this as a as
a house of
God
um I subsequently you know on another
visit sitting there met the Imam and he
gave me a Quran and now it's true you
know for years I've had a quan on my
bookshelf I barely touched
it uh but this time I I I went back to
my hotel and you know I prostrated and
asked God you know show me the absolute
truth show me whether Islam is true or
false whether Christianity is right or
wrong whether Orthodox Christianity is
right or wrong and I prayed for some
time on my knees
prostrate uh Orthodox Christians
actually prostrate in a in a way very
similar to to to Islamic sujud uh
especially in penitential Seasons anyway
I was used to prostration I
prostrated and prayed and then I sat up
and I read Quran
and I I
realized you know uh intuitively uh
intellectually emotionally spiritually
that this was the the actual word of God
that I
had not paid heed to not paid respect to
and I read it with completely different
eyes and I just knew I I I instantly
knew that this was the absolute truth
and that I could no longer ignore
it uh so you know I I
went uh I went and talked further with
the
Imam and and uh and stood probably
awkwardly and and and through M prayers
at the back of the of the
Masjid and then I had to fly back to
Tasmania and I flew back
and um reflected
and I could not continue on as
before um so I prayed and I read Quran
and you know the only way I could go
back to what I was serving as a priest
in the way that I was was to was to say
that what I had felt and known and
understood was a lie and I could not do
it um you know was I unhappy being a
priest no was I I you
know
um uh and you know I was a priest that
wasn't paid to be a priest I worked
full-time because my Parish was so small
you know that uh I work I'm a hospital
social
worker working with many Muslim
colleagues as it turns out uh
alhamdulillah and
um so I wrote to my
Bishop uh you know a letter that
was easy to write on level of course
difficult to write a letter that is
severing ties of a of a lifetime and
pulling out from a community that I had
committed to
serve and I declared
um shahada in that letter to the bishop
there is no God but Allah and that
Muhammad the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon Him is his last messenger and that
this is the final
message and that I had no choice no
choice but to obey it
uh so alhamdulillah
I contacted the Imam in
Perth uh and took Shahara over the
telephone uh and then that was on a
Wednesday and then on the Friday I went
to Juma at the massud in
Hobart um there were some brothers over
here doing dawa from uh big Masid in
Melbourne
Faulkner you know uh M that I now have
connection with uh and uh and so took
shahada in front of the community and of
course was humbled in a in a Masid full
of people packed with people packed with
Brothers to have everyone coming to
congratulate
me
um so that's uh you know the story about
how uh this Orthodox
priest uh you know not a senior priest
not a Sly priest priest a sinner but you
know how uh I could not
ignore Quran could not ignore the truth
that God is not three God is one that
God has
no no
son uh and that his final message was
the message that all of us all
Christians everyone needs to hear that I
needed to pray as Jesus
prayed to pray as the prophets that were
honored you know
uh well prayed uh and you know I've been
at peace with this
decision um since I want to back it up
uh for uh many of the non-muslims not
yet Muslims who watch this and when you
say Allah I mean many people if you look
back isn't this now in the language that
that Jesus spoke of course in in you
knowa Aramaic is so so close to the
Arabic and of course Christians today
you know um Copic Christians and and
Christians in the Middle East that are
Arabic um Palestinian Christians use
Allah for God uh in the in in the same
way of course
their understanding of God is is nuanced
and different but the language is the
same and and I and I think you know
there's this
immense
um relief this satisfaction that you
know the world's largest religion Islam
is the completion of what God uh
delivered to
Moses and to the prophets to the prophet
David you know my my my my Christian
namesake I'm David named uh you know to
um Prophet Elias to and of course to
Jesus um peace be upon him you know to
all the messengers so there's this Con
uh congu
congruity
that we as Christians have have missed
and misunderstood what's the difference
of how you honor and respect Jesus now
because you didn't abandon Jesus what's
your relationship with Jesus now you
know I would say I I I love Jesus no
less than I love Jesus before but I have
I understand Jesus in proper P
relationship perspective to God
Almighty that's the difference you know
that you know most Christians that that
that seriously look at Quran are amazed
that you know that we have uh surra you
know in honor of Mary the mother of
Jesus you know the most spoken of woman
in uh in Quran um and of course a woman
highly revered and respected by uh you
know by by Christian Christians and by
Orthodox
Christians um in
particular um you know
and you know then there a major
um comfort to a Christian becoming
Muslim and knowing that you are not
abandoning Jesus you're not abandoning
Mary you're placing them in correct
relationship to Allah uh and that's the
difference and that in that sense makes
that trans
translation from one to the other are
easy of course you know there are
cultural differences there are there's
so much to
learn
um of course there's the notion that
when one takes Shahara that that that
our that our sins and our failings are
wiped and that we have the opportunity
to uh have a new relationship with God
that
is um in the right situ
situation and you know Mar Allah I I I
have not looked
back um that doesn't mean I don't love
and respect the people that I served the
friendships that I
made uh and regret the loss of
friendships that that go with this kind
of a change but uh you know it's the
price that I pay for obedience to God
and it is and you know as challenging as
it can be on a human level on on a
spiritual level it's what I must do you
know it's the um it's a sacrifice for
for Allah it reminds me when you open up
the Bible when you talk about shahada
and you look at John
173 it says that this is eternal life
that they may know you the only true God
and Jesus Christ who you sent so you
would have said that Jesus is the
messenger at that time yes now the final
messenger is Prophet Muhammad and you
are worshiping the one that Jesus says
is greater than him God Almighty Allah
so you're putting Jesus in the place
where he put himself not elevating him
to God you're worshiping worshiping the
god of Jesus and accepting him as a
messenger as a prophet of God and then
Muhammad peace and blessing be upon them
all as just the final messenger the
completion of the chain of Messengers
that came since the beginning until the
end he was the
final I I mean that you know that that
the Quran is is full of you know um you
know there so much teaching is the same
you know the uh so much so much account
is the same of of Moses in Egypt of
pharaoh of The Parting of the Red
Sea of you
know of uh you know God's punishment of
uh wrongful
people of uh God's mercy and for
forgiveness uh to those that love and
Obey him you know
um so on one level this journey is very
similar but it's you know it's it's gone
from the basis of incorrect belief to
right belief and of course that you know
that that's ultimately what Orthodoxy
means you know right belief and and
Islam is has right belief so so were you
uh before
1978 I I was I I was an Anglican so you
know I'm an Aussie an Australian I I was
raised in Anglican and Anglican yeah so
that's you know the Church of
England uh see some would call it
Protestant some would say reformed
Catholic uh you know different labels
when um you know when when the anglian
church uh ordained women as clergy in
cont vention of of scripture in
contravention of all tradition uh I knew
that this couldn't be of God that this
this you know this was you know you know
that this was done and uh and so I
looked for conservative Christianity
that hadn't changed this and it hadn't
changed other things you know that
called liberalism that you know
Christianity today as you as you know
especially in the West in the west not
in the East and and and not in Africa
and places is has this uh belief that if
you have this reproach me with with the
world you know if you
have gay marriage if you have you know
now you have you know the Church of
England saying oh we've got a
transgender Bishop you know which would
have been wow uh you know insane um I
remember an Anglican priest when I was a
boy laughing and saying this will never
happen here this you know women priest
could never happen here so I think you
know when you
have you know Christianity is not built
on on on the solidity of Islam we have
you know we have Quran which has not
changed a
word not a word pres Allah handed it
down the Bible as we know you know they
had to decide the fathers of the church
hundreds of years after after the life
of Jesus peace be upon him you know
which books in which books out Catholics
say these are in orthodox say no these
extra books are in Protestants say no
all these books are out so you know they
they can't agree so for the people that
don't know it was the church was it was
it the church that put the Bible
together absolutely
yes the church you know put the Bible
together you know Matthew Mark Luke and
John are not the authors you know
they're ascribed to those those
personalities but in reality we don't
know who wrote The Who wrote the first
uh four books of the Gospel then who who
wrote them well do we know author is
unknown really you know which is why you
have you know you you have um which is
why John's gospel has significant
differences to Matthew Mark and Luke so
you know there there
are there are things that are similar
and there are things that are unique to
each of those books um and then of
course you have St Paul who came
afterwards you know St Paul the
the uh you know the Jew who supposedly
had his road to Damascus
Enlightenment and and who significantly
changed many things you know changed the
Christian response to the
law uh you know essentially shifted
things from you know he he made the
first big shift from where from what was
at the time of Jesus Jesus didn't you
know abolish Everything Jesus prayed as
as you know as his forbears prayed to
God you know in prostration in SED in uh
you know to the one God you know he
prayed that way in the Garden of
Gethsemane uh so you know Paul changed
much and and then and then you know
Constantinople the emperor when you know
the Roman Empire became Christian and
Christianity was made the religion of
the Empire then there was massive
change massive change so you know and
you've had that through to the
Protestant Reformation you have that in
the 21st century with you know these
changing attitudes to morality to to to
um so theology you know has changed with
that uh of course for some Christians it
hasn't changed there are Christians who
are you know in their own way as
conservative as as as Muslims are but
there is not
the incontrovertible Foundation that is
in
Islam is the uh the difference between
because most people when they heard
priest they think Catholic priest of
course yeah what's the difference
between the Catholic priest and the kind
of priest you you're the Orthodox
Christian priest well or Orthodox
Orthodox priests there are you know if
you like two varieties married and
unmarried so uh you know Christian
clergy were married from from you know
the early days of Christianity uh you
know leaders were married uh clergy were
married um and it only became you know a
much later you know uh you know
essentially 10th 11th 12th century of
creation or in the west under under Rome
that uh that celibacy was made mandatory
for all clergy and in the East um that
was never the case and so you have a
tradition both you know the the East has
a very strong monastic tradition and
Bishops that you know the the the
seniors come from the ranks of monastics
uh whereas whereas most you know 95% of
all Parish clergy are
married uh you know I guess experiencing
the normal things of life that go with
being married so Orthodox priests can
get married yes Catholicism you have the
confession boxes in Orthodox priest you
don't have that do you you have
confession in Orthodoxy but there's not
a box per se but there there there is
you know uh the Orthodox understanding
is that your confession is to God and
the priest is a witness so help us
understand so you have um subdeacon
Deacon and then you have priest yep and
then after that you have you know
Bishops after that
have Bishop so I it reminds me of uh a a
friend of mine also I've interviewed he
was the late me Grant him Jenna his name
is uh Dr Gerald Dirks he was also a
deacon in the Methodist Church and he
had a doctor in Divinity and he when he
went to the Seminary school and he took
a deep dive into the into the Bible and
textual criticism and whatnot and he saw
kind of what you're talking reminding me
of yourself and he said I I couldn't I
couldn't get back under Pulpit I
couldn't I couldn't get out there in
things that I knew that weren't the orig
in anything that we have of a copy of a
copy a copy of in the original I
couldn't get out there and preach many
of these things that I had been
preaching before and he was a man of
integrity and later he he ended up
accepting Islam kind of similar to your
story Dr Gerald
Dirks so uh this struggle this struggle
happened for how many years when this uh
you know I I would say on one level you
know it predated me being a priest this
struggle with you know I I um you know I
looked I looked at Buddhism I looked at
uh you know other versions of
Christianity you know through those
years before I was clergy I I I I really
looked and and some of it you know I
went to things and you know where is and
the one place of course I didn't
substantially go to was Islam you went
through everything else except Islam
this usually what uh is the same thing I
get from from many other people and
um it's hard to explain why that was uh
is it because there's such a stigma
there's so many misconceptions and
people have maybe maybe there are
misconceptions about it like you know
it's just you know that
whole islamophobic thing about
fanaticism and and on one level you know
Christianity with its doctrinally and
how it's lived and and how the church is
is incredibly
complicated and Islam
is simplistic in its you know in its
requirements of us of course they are
great requirements but you know it's
it's uh you know maybe I felt it was too
simple you know how could it be you know
that simple that you know God is one
that we're required to you know to do
these simple things pray five times a
day you know to fast in Ramadan to give
zaka you know th those pillars you know
to to to go on hjj you know those those
pillars on one level seem very simple
it's pretty straightforward it's not
comp uh and yet you know what I've
realized since becoming a Muslim is
there is a depth of wisdom and
um
um uh a great depth of knowledge and
insight that supports us to apply Islam
in our daily
life in in what Scholars have said in uh
you know in
writings uh but you know fundamentally
we have this one
book that is the word of God the
incontrovertible word of God uh and we
have the sunna you know we have the
prophet and his example and uh you know
we have you know the
understanding of what the
companions you know their
qualities uh so there's a Simplicity
that I think is very appealing and you
know in the west today you know we have
my God you know we
have a breakdown of you know the West
you know as a
Christian uh focused
continent and and Society you know has
Within my lifetime
abandoned so much you know when I was a
child everyone went to church on Sundays
pretty much most people or if they
didn't go parents sent their kids to
church now no one does now you know more
people don't get married and get married
more you
know the whole you know notion what is
male and female let alone all this
diverse gender stuff and sexuality stuff
it's a radical reshaping of
of of um of society as we know it and
here we have Islam which is you know
growing in the west
exponentially uh with this you know
solidity and uh certainty and Community
you know I haven't even talked about
that Community my
goodness this notion of the um this
notion of this Brotherhood and
Sisterhood of Believers is profound in
Islam in a way that I haven't seen in
anything any
experience including the church H how
did you tackle with um the crucifixion
now someone says okay you believe in one
God and this is all nice but who's dying
for your sins who's paying the price
what's the answer in Islam that you
found the concept of salvation of
sin the answer is that you know is that
we're accountable for our
own life lives our own actions and and
we're responsible for our own salvation
we're responsible you know we'll be
judged every human being will be judged
on the day of judgment you know we have
an
angel writing down you know everything
you know you know the Bible itself
confirms that you know you know the
gospel says not a blade of grass moves
without God knowing it you know consider
the you know the birds of the air that
God provides for
them without any human
intervention you know nothing nothing is
not known by Allah so you know
ultimately my reversion to
Islam is you know between me and my
Creator uh and I'll answer for that
gladly answer for that on the day of
judgment that's
beautiful finish sorry my you know my
responsibility is to finish the
course you
know that's that's another uh beautiful
thing along with the uh pure monotheism
we call the toed the Oneness of God and
then the whole concept of turning to who
you named your your name the ABD ABD
rman uh the servant of the most merciful
that
God I I chose that name
because I
I uh you know I want to be the servant
of the most merciful and I acknowledge
that for me as a lifelong sinner that
uh that it is the action of the merciful
that has brought me to Islam not my own
action yes so the most merciful the most
loving you turn to the most loving you
know you know this notion of uh that
that people have in the West in
particular you know maybe colored by
events I don't know that Islam is
somehow har and that you know that we
have
this Fierce God is is so wrong yeah you
know go through the 99 Names of Allah
you
know he you know those qualities of
Mercy compassion
forgiveness are so profoundly
strong and you know this is you know
Allah is perpetually open to us being
repentant
um so you know there is profound hope in
Islam for Humanity and uh that dispels
the the myth what you just said there is
uh because Allah being the most merciful
the most compassionate is when you turn
to him alone and you seek uh repentance
and you seek his forgiveness he forgives
all
sins absolutely yes so this is one the
beauties of his Islam and it's it's so
beautiful and right there you dispelled
another myth you have Orthodox priest
accepting Islam submission to the will
of the Creator and I often say that this
is in the Lord's Prayer Islam Oh Our
Father who are in heaven Hallowed be thy
name thy kingdom come thy will be done
that's Islam your will be done this is
Islam absolutely this is what Islam mean
you're just doing God's will you're not
doing something uh something weird
something strange you're doing what
Jesus did you submitted not to Jesus but
you submit to the the god of Jesus the
Lord of Jesus you absolutely you're
submitting to you know the god of Isaac
and Abraham you're subit to the god of
Moses you you're submitting to the one
who
created uh Adam and Eve you're
submitting to the one who created
everything that's it simple plain and
simple it almost seems too simple it's
like this is the most logical conclusion
there that this is the truth absolutely
yeah tell us what what else can you
share uh before we conclude uh
uh so you started reading the Quran and
what what else did it for you so you one
of the things was the preservation of
the Quran the simple message of the pure
monotheism of worshiping one and only
one God is there anything else that
captivated you about you
know this notion of you know
believe just believe
and uh you know I felt that so strongly
and
then you know when I took Shahara I felt
such
peace uh alhamdulillah such peace and
then you know when you experience this
wraparound love of community for you and
support um you know it has
been humbling to
see you know the to experience to see to
feel to experience the um in uh living
uh
Islam and you know
there's I'm really takeen with uh you
know in Christianity you know as a
priest I prayed Lots it's true uh but
you know the the discipline of uh the
five daily
prayers and making that sh that life is
shaped around this and not around other
things that our life that our that our
material life is shaped around our
spiritual
life um and not the other way around
um so you know
um for me that's that's been an
unfolding uh
happiness uh to to experience that of
course you know I'm a I'm a neifi I'm
learning um I'm hoping I've just you
know started with a um with a teacher
for learning quranic
Arabic uh from uh the community at
forkner in Melbourne
um uh I uh you know I've had some great
experiences I I I went you know to um
the massud at forner where you know with
150 Brothers all spending 24 hours
together and you know there were shakes
from Saudi there and it was you know who
spoke English and it was just the most
fantastic learning and experience and
teaching so you know inshallah um yes
umah and and one day Hajj is my hope uh
you know in Tasmania where I am which is
you know the Island state to the south
of Tasmania you know uh you know there
are
about uh 20 20,000 Muslims now there was
one mid for the whole
island um and now there are
three three three and and and a couple
of prayer rooms you know we uh H we we
need to build a new or or massively
extend the the mud that we have in the
capital in hovah because it's not big
enough um so you know our our uh
Community here is growing and uh
um uh alhamdulillah that's you know a
great thing to be part of so this is a
city in Australia Hobart yeah so it's
the Mania is the island state to the
south of of Mainland
Australia uh it has a population of half
a million just under half a million
Capital has 200,000 people so it's small
by by you know by many
standards uh and it's you know largely a
rural um Place uh you know it has some
industry but a rural place so um but you
know alhamdulillah you know there are
people bit by bit embracing Islam also
um we have new
arrivals from you know elsewhere in the
world that are you know migrating here
so we have you know a very diverse
community of uh of of Muslims
here what uh go ahead you finish your
point you're right thank you yeah tell
me what advice do you have for someone
else like uh yourself who they are in a
mirage of um many of the falsehoods that
are perpetuated against Islam much of
this islamophobia industry it's a
billion dollar industry and there's so
much fear and apprehension stereotypes
stigma attached to Islam but they're
looking at you and they they like what
you have to say you know they're also
been confused about this Trinity
confused about the purpose of life you
know death can be a right around the
corner we don't know how long you know
we're going to be on this Earth and they
are list absolutely and you know that
that uh that was a you know a major
motive in me saying I need to take
shahada now because you know no one
knows you know I work in a hospital I um
I see death as a as a very regular event
deal with it as an issue um and uh you
know God Alone knows when our time is
you know not a blade of grass moves
without his will well you know our life
ends when he wills it and we don't know
when that is uh and you know
where you know committing of you know sh
by by by assuming that you know we're
going to live forever even the you know
the Bible Old Testament you know says
that you know three score years and 10
is that is is is our lifespan and any
more than this you know is is toil and
suffering so we don't know um but uh so
I would say to people that are
considering Islam
is uh get a copy of Quran and read ask
God uh in your heart with humility with
love to say please show me the
truth um and also try and look at Islam
in the lens through the lens of this
understanding that it is uh the
completion that that it's you know
Christianity
as uh as Jesus lived it we pray as Jesus
prayed that we love and respect Jesus
peace be upon him we love and respect
his mother we uh love and respect the
prophets before so there's a continuity
between us going back to
Adam um you know the first man that is
uh that is there so if you look at it
through that lens and not through the
lens
of you know islamophobia of of politics
of um you
know uh you know of the sinful actions
of some
you know uh you
know being Muslim doesn't make us uh
immune to sinning but you know we uh you
know we have a an accountability before
our creator uh and a
responsibility uh and that's why you'll
find that
um that Muslims truly are a community of
peace and of uh love uh and
of um
shared love of God and community and uh
so Muslims are not a community to be
feared uh Muslims are a community that
you that you should be curious about uh
and you know masjids are open places
mosques are open places so come visit um
you know you will find uh you know in
all over the Western World you know
you'll find Western convert revert
Muslims um and you'll find us uh side by
side with our you know brothers or
sisters from all over the world uh and
of course reverts as
well um and you know we're we're one
people you know there's no
nationality uh there's no one culture in
Islam we're one people of
God uh so alhamdulillah please
um uh you know know that uh that that I
certainly I as a Muslim um does that
mean I you know I have no love and
respect for Christians no I of course I
do uh including people that I prayed
with uh worked with shared life with uh
and for me I wish that they would um see
the beauty of what I've seen in Islam
see the truth of what I've seen in Islam
uh and consider that and and pray to God
for that and seek his guidance and
direction
beautiful beautiful advice thank you I
was honored to uh to meet you here for
this
interview may God Almighty Allah
continue to bless you along this
journey thank you brother so you know
my you know my advice is get this get
this book and uh and
um and you know embibe of its wisdom and
its truth and uh and know that it's the
final revelation of almighty
God uh and that there's a Clarity there
that we all need and that the world
hugely needs at this time absolutely
needs absolutely
alhamdulillah thank you my brother thank
you thank you a pleasure talking to you
uh I you know it was a great happiness
as a new Muslim to find the dean show
and
um uh and you know I'll look forward to
uh to continuing to watch your show and
uh and to uh and to supporting it thank
you thank you very much thank you great
talking AUM Salam a very good friend of
mine brother Eddie from the dean show
who I've known for a number of years
from the very beginning when he started
it I was among his early guests and
mashallah our brother Eddie has been
very active in promoting daah spreading
The Message of Islam and he has now
taken everything to the next level Eddie
has now after a number of years on The
Dean show taken the daup efforts to the
next level which is that of establishing
a dawa center for the USA he is about to
launch it in its fullness but it has
already started in Florida and he needs
your support this is an effort which
began already some months back and they
need your support for spreading The
Message of Islam in the USA so my
brothers and sisters reach out to
support him we need your support
now and if you uh I cannot leave without
giving you a gift if you're not yet
Muslim and you're tuning in to see what
these Muslims are talking about and you
like a free copy of the Quran go ahead
and visit theen show.com we'll take care
of the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions about Islam call us at
8006 62 4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalam
alaikum